my name is Steve Zimmer I'm president of
the school board Los Angeles Unified
School District I'd like to speak if I
could directly to families and employees
we are taking this action in an
abundance of caution to make sure that
every child in LA Unified School
District and every employee is
absolutely safe right now we ask parents
and families if you have not yet sent
your children to school please do not
send them to school if they have already
been dropped off we will have families
meet their children at the reunion gates
of all schools I want to be very clear
we need the cooperation of the whole of
Los Angeles today we need families and
neighbors to work together with our
schools and with our employees to make
sure our kids are safe throughout the
day we need employers to show the
flexibility the situation like this
demands and we ask you to show the
maximum possible flexibility with your
employees who are primarily mothers and
fathers and guardians today in this
situation our school sites we have asked
administrators and plant managers to
report we are not we are asking for
teachers and other support personnel to
stay home today once again I want to
reiterate on behalf of the entire Board
of Education our support for the
superintendent
for the chief of police the actions that
we are taking today are Swift and they
are appropriate given the situation that
we are in and we ask for the patience
and the cooperation and support of the
city the education of our kids is
incredibly important the only thing
that's more important is their safety
and the superintendent has acted in
regards to that safety this morning